l'école des groupes de paris première
année cours de rattrapage petit fils de
ses huit fils deux élites c'est l'idée
serait même voici les plus beaux
fleurons de l'hôtellerie française
ils vont réaliser devant vous quelques
leçons de style d'abord à un gros on
doit savoir sourire ce manoir huit
heures par jour
attention un client une cliente le
client d'autres allègent le pire de très
jolies
qu'est ce que vous faites vous souhaitez
savoir où clients très jolie attention à
vienne lui n'aura qu'à noël et moi il
s'est laissé 0 0 et voilà pourquoi vous
que doyen des grooms de paris deuxième
exercice l'équipe du pont en bois rond
point savoir recevoir un pourvoir à
consommer sion reçoit pour boire un
pourboire un trop petit pour moi un beau
pour moi énorme bobard à pourboire
princier un roi du pétrole
rendez vous on peut pas aller plus bas
et la tempe pourquoi on reçoit le piège
c'est le piège lui raquel welch ville à
ce dialogue je le dise mais vous pensez
tout ça vous êtes obsédé droit droit
l'étude de la promenade du petit chien
très important messieurs le matin 8
heures on est un petit chien un petit
chat de petits chats ces petits chats un
gros chien si gros choc puis voilà vous
vous êtes blessé en partie ils ont
rappelé si vous revenez tout six vous
rendez vous pour et de vous sortez tout
sorti j'étais en promenade était en
promenade
qu'est ce que vous allez promenez-vous
elle raconte celui ci nous reprendre
après quatre exercices un gros mot de
connaître l'histoire et son pays
les smart france pour répondre à une
question d'un client par exemple voici
quelques tableaux vivants
attention messieurs rampon
vercingétorix vaincu alésia ses parents
à droite vers saint jo oryx au centre
aussant césar jus à gauche un gaulois
qu'est ce que c'est que ça une gauloise
mais c'est pas des pokes ses droits un
garde très bien fait sans qu'il y ait eu
ce sens bien souviens toi du vase de
soissons c'est frappant à droite le 10
aussant qui a passé la barre bras gauche
un franc et c'est pas cher un gars alors
lui et moi ça fait deux ans avait rien
du tout se fait pas deux fois
tu veux pas affronter un wisigoths tu
pars en fonte mais je ne me fais invités
à petit avion du futur 3 je ne viens me
repousse les uns à droite la sainte
hausse en un an à gauche ni à droite
mais je peux pas faire le grand non un
gros naze existe mais ne fait plus ne
parle parce qu'il parle de ça on va
maquiller mon chouchou valeur du nominal
maintenant charlemagne visite les écoles
aux centres charme
le mind avec sa barre à droite un bonnet
vert à gauche en mauvaises élèves
8 les 8-14 plus de 16 et les progrès un
garde
c'est une garderie d'enfants
la poste a thousand à entend des voix
pour la première fois à droite saint nom
ça fait la deuxième somme au sens non
gabriel a donc à ce que vous faites vous
un mouton un goût trop un garde
je préfère le chien moi quel chien bo le
chien de garde de terre tu veux te taire
je veux tu veux te souhaiter maintenant
leur attention messieurs entrevue du
camp du drap d'or
alma françois 1er au 100 ans 18 à gauche
que je vous fais une tente une perte de
temps due peut pas garder le terrain de
conflit mais attention messieurs les
anglais tirez bon et premier m'avait
fait signe j'ai pas des petits reste le
seul moyen c'est en somme c'est à droite
les anglais ont semblé français à gauche
a confié tout fait alors moi je suis
suisse les suisses à gauche un garde
républicain est républicain
oui oui je pouvais pas être belge plutôt
joué à faire le mal vous fera sans
culottes et sociale cds
oui mais c'est la même occasion tu
m'intéresses en culotte mais rentrer
c'est trop tard beaucoup attention rouge
et ludique une chambre la marseillaise
alors où je vais offre de l'île aux cent
le pianiste de roubaix à gombe
qu'est ce que vous faites un piano un
plat nos droits sont à vienne au droit
un garde républicain trop tard
et enfin pour terminer une plaisanterie
grecque dans vos places le cheval de
troie comment rester là vous vous allez
voir une grande chanteuse et maintenant
tu es garbo h d'après camp